[Musique]
moi la france et alain delon mais
maintenant c'est difficile pour moi la
france c'est aux gens de corto pour moi
la france c'était le standard et moi
hier pour moi la fin c'était le pierrot
le fou de jean luc godard mois la france
s'était nicole belge est dans un film
intitulé blé en herbe j'avais 14 ans à
l'époque 2000 français risquent à tokyo
rémy japonais dit là bas ils ont leurs
boutiques le restaurant leurs journaux
et à deux pas de la place du trocadéro
une école qui essaie de ne pas faire
perdre aux enfants les bonnes habitudes
japonais
ouais
[Musique]
non
les japonais sont est survenu le premier
droit est un devoir respecter l'autre et
savoir vivre ensemble résider en france
c'est pour certains un soulagement pour
d'autres un bouleversement à la vie
quotidienne à paris c'est les français
rentrent à la maison sensé et chaussées
les français gardent leurs voitures sur
les trottoirs les français ne respectent
pas les feux rouges dans les métros il
ya des ya des gens qui passent sont payé
le billet moi j'ai trouvé comme défaut
des français ne sommes pas en
vieillissant et les autres défauts des
ministres des français sont très longues
parce que si quelqu'un dit à part de
moyenne minutes mais on n'a pas ça que
six minutes comme qualité j'ai trouvé
les parents des français joue beaucoup
avec leurs enfants
les français bien beaucoup la nature les
français laissent les places assises ou
personnes âgées comme des fous j'ai
trouvé les français mange en marchant
les français garland voiture en
habillement cedith des voisins les
français font beaucoup de graal les
français se mettent en colère facilement
les français ne sont pas accueillants
[Musique]
aujourd'hui j'ai vu un jeune garçon qui
a glissé sur la route était tout mouillé
ici personnes à aider tout le monde le
regarde comme ça quand c'est un cirque
mais c'est incroyable je n'ai jamais vu
ça au japon mais je sais pas vous êtes
froid ou quoi paris est bon mais je ne
peux pas dire que je suis amoureuse de
paris
les gens ne sont pas très gentils ils me
font peur il se fâche ce bon moi quand
je me fâche
je ne peux pas le montrer pour ne pas
blesser des autres mais les parisiens si
il me semble que la différence entre les
français les japonais sait que les
français ont tendance à croire que
l'homme est né foncièrement mauvais il
s'en méfie alors que nous les japonais
nous croyons contraire que l'homme est
né foncièrement bon en lui faisons
confiance
miranda va craquer il aura d'autres cas
est peut-être que ce climat est dû au
fait que l'enseignement en france est
basé essentiellement sur l'accumulation
de connaissances
alors qu'au japon on insiste beaucoup
sur l'enseignement de la morale 14
vanille dans nos classes on invite
fréquemment les enfants à réfléchir sur
des formules telles que il faut penser
aux autres et il faut aider son prochain
quand il est dans l'embarras
l'amour avec français un peu bizarre au
japon il y a un très lourd et puis sexe
est très grande distance était très
sérieuse mais ici bon quand on se
connaît depuis en costaud suite même les
copains ça et vous souvent et puis bon
c'était bien et puis après le l'amour on
fume on téléphone voilà bon jeu mama
comment vas tu t'es d'où vous vient
faire la cuisine bon ils sont pas très
salée ouzou il n'y a pas beaucoup de
sentiments
je trouve vraiment comme messi et puis
bon par exemple j'ai un copain il me
disait tu sais j'suis fatigué
aujourd'hui parce que je faisais le
sport hollis poli je me suis dit mais
j'ai compris que c'était faire l'amour
mais c'est terrible de dire des choses
comme ça ils disent spoerli ben je crois
que ils font l'amour 5 octobre comme un
boeuf comme on mange ou prendre un café
à faire quelque chose très facile pour
mais tu donc c'est il faut faire plus
les japonais font pour nous c'est que ce
trait s'est créé et puis bon moi j'ai
des moments mais c'est fait rien mon
petit but c'est mon petit l'a pas mon
petit poussin mais je sais pas la pole
je suis pas pour moi la france c'est le
dise toujours je t'aime je t'aime
je t'aime je t'aime ça finit jamais 1
ils disent tous ça et ma chérie est ce
que tu m'aimes tu es fidèles étaient
tous mais je crois que je n'ai on n'a
pas besoin de dire tout ça tout le temps
parce que par exemple j'ai quand j'étais
petit j'ai vu mes parents on était tous
les trois autour de télévision est en
train de regarder un film alors tout
d'un coup ma mère les soulever comme ça
et terrifiant d'été il est revenu est
ami donc donc à un comédien verre de thé
devant mon père à mon pays la regarde
comme ça il m'a dit ah tiens justement
je voulais vous rendez vous comprenez
avec ça on peut déjà se voit l'amour où
on n'a pas besoin dit je t'aime ont
regardé comme ça les yeux on n'a pas
besoin avec ça j'ai compris qu'ils
s'aiment ils sont vraiment ensemble tu
vois une femme un homme cette voie là
[Musique]